nos jours les chiens on s'est demandé à
quoi pouvait ressembler si vous étiez un
chien moi j'ai une petite idée mais
voilà alors vous par mme delphine oui
très belle part d'elfi que ça donnerait
quoi delphine télé
oui
alors vous
[Applaudissements]
sauvez
la sapso et moi j'avais un shih tzu qui
ressemble vraiment beaucoup on veut
chercher
c'est un chic je suis sûr que c'est un
chihuahua
et
vous serez géorgie
on se bat
bougies base ils doivent aller briller
non non non c'est une heure bien
[Rires]
ma vie isabelle hains
alors
c'est également
l'heure vous vers la montée elle va voir
c'est mon bébé devant une lampe peut
arriver je vois alors donné mort ou
alors il fallait quelque chose de vivant
on a fait quoi
[Rires]
mais il ya quelque chose et enfin vous
c'est un peu un chien savant mon avis